[Musique]
cinq des plus grands châteaux de la
loire célèbre l'esprit des fêtes de fin
d'année et propose ainsi un nouveau
parcours de visite noël gourmand noël
des sapins noël fleury chacun des sites
participants décline une thématique
différente on château de langeais par
exemple la mise en lumière est à
l'honneur au château de langeais on a
choisi de travailler sur la lumière
puisque au moyen-age on pouvait trouver
dans les châteaux des des bougies
allumées à cette époque là enfin de
toute manière toute l'année mais encore
plus en période de noël
et puis la bougie de cire était quand
même un élément de luxe dans les
châteaux du moyen-âge étant une demeure
seigneuriale
on a voulu du coup décorer notre château
sur ce thème là langer célèbre noël pour
la troisième année consécutive et la
fréquentation comme sur les autres sites
il y a explosé + 50 % la première année
et encore plus 40 l'an dernier
l'opération noël au pays des châteaux
semble bien correspondre à une attente
des visiteurs
d'une part vous avez l'émergence d'une
clientèle étrangère lointaine je pense
au brésilien pardon je pense aux russes
qui voyagent à cette période de l'année
et qu'ils avaient besoin de trouver un
val de loire et une touraine animé et
non pas des choses une destination un
petit peu éteinte donc que sont très
demandeurs et puis après on a toute la
clientèle française aussi pour qui le
mois de décembre est devenu un mois très
important c'est le moi on se retrouve en
famille peut-être même davantage qu'on
était maintenant et qu'on a envie de
faire des choses ensemble
donc c'est aussi un prétexte pour les
tourangeaux pour les habitants de la
région centre et puis même pour les
parisiens et les nantais qui sont nos
publics cibles de venir partager quelque
chose en famille à un moment où on a
envie de faire
outreau langer chenonceaux amboise
chinon et azay-le-rideau s'empare de
l'esprit de noël
il s'agit à terme de proposer une offre
touristique ambitieuse complémentaire à
cette époque des marchés de noël ou des
stations de ski par exemple
[Musique]